this report from CBS news says Los
Angeles County will officially move to a
zero bail system on Sunday ending the
yearlong standard of setting cash bail
amounts for defendants commensurate with
the severity of the crime that they're
commus accused of committing a process
critic say favors the rich while doing
little to protect Public Safety but the
zero bail system has come under Fire
from Hardline Law and Order backers who
can tend to removes accountability from
the justice system by allowing the vast
majority of arrestes to be quickly
released from custody rather than kept
in jail as they await charges in trial
unless they're accused of the most
serous of
crimes County Sheriff Robert Luna told
the Board of Supervisors last week our
communities have not been shy about
telling us how nervous they are about
this
change he said he understands the need
to respect constitutional rights of
arrestes but said zero bail can
demoralize deputies and police officers
who work hard to make arrests only to
watch the offender walk away with the
citation as the victim looks on in
disbelief yeah that's one of the
consequences of a zero bail system
before we talk about this the LA County
uh da George gascan who is a Soros
Goblin one of the worst dasas in the
country one of the worst human beings in
the country period he was interviewed
this week by the fox affiliate the local
Fox affiliate in Los Angeles and um
asked about the zero bail system and
here's what he said do you think that
cash bail is unconstitutional you know I
believe that how much money you have in
your bank account should not determine
whether you're going to get out or not
LA County district attorney George
gasone sits down with us on the week LA
County enacts a judge's order to switch
to a so-called zeroc cash bail system
meaning most suspects will now be
quickly released from custody except for
those accused of the most serious crimes
I strongly believe that if you have an
open case you should not be released if
we determine that you're at djur to our
community you should not be released it
doesn't matter how much money you have
12 LA County cities are suing to try and
stop this policy out of public safety
concerns do you agree with them I don't
I think they're fighting this saying we
want to get rid of it all together and
go back to the way the system was before
it flies in the face of reality that the
old system wasn't working big picture
for people that are concerned that this
is going to make LA County less safe and
people are going to be held less
accountable what say you what I say is
that there are things that need to be
improved we're going to work on them I
don't believe that longterm thises is
going to make the county less safe I
think it's going to make us safer
because it's going to create more room
in our County Jail to hold the people
that are dangerous he says that includes
suspects accused
so you know what I could tell this guy's
a pathetic without knowing anything
about him if I didn't know anything
about him I could already tell that he's
a pathetic weakling and an awful da um
without without knowing anything about
him without even paying attention to the
content of what he's saying it's just
his whole vibe the way he
speaks oh you know uh crime's a problem
and we'll we'll we're work hard we'll
work hard on it it's a problem we're
working on the
problem you could this is not someone
who hungers for justice you could tell
that much right off the bat and he says
that um this will make the city safer
because it creates more room for violent
criminals in the jail so but the
question then is that are you actually
going to put the violent criminals in
jail are you going to do that and is
there actually a problem right now where
you have violent criminals who you want
to put in jail and you would put in jail
but you can't because there's no room is
that a real thing that's actually
happening is there someone walking
around the streets right now in Los
Angeles there's a violent criminal has
been arrested and you tried to put him
in jail and and they said sorry you know
No Vacancy no room at the
end is that is is that actually
happening I don't I don't buy that for
one second I don't buy it for one second
it's total
nonsense you know this is always the
excuse made by the uh anti- Law and
Order folks on the left oh we need more
room we need we need more room in the in
the jails for the really violent and
dangerous
people yeah and then when when when the
violent and dangerous people get
arrested what are those same people say
they well you know he's we he's he's
reformed he's he's not a danger this is
someone who's been persecuted by
systemic racism we we you we we need to
worry about reforming and not punishment
that's what they
say and besides if you do have a problem
with capacity limits it's an easy
problem to solve number one build build
more jails okay that's one thing you
could do and uh and in the meantime if
you have too many violent criminals to
fit in a jail then um I guess the
violent criminals are going to be more
uncomfortable just Jam them in there
okay what do you mean there's no space
put them in there find find spot for
them I don't care if they're on they're
not going to be comfortable there too
many people who cares who gives a damn
if they're comfortable or not they're in
jail that's their problem Al El Salvador
you know they take a jail with a
capacity of 5,000 and they put like
50,000 people in there they find a way
to do it so it can be
done but I don't think that's the issue
at all I think that's an absolute lie on
his part his objective is not to get
more dangerous people in jail it is to
get people out of jail because that's
what he's doing and it's the opposite
obviously of what you should be doing if
your city is plagued with crime what you
should be doing is finding ways to put
more people in jail for longer not
finding ways to let more people
out or make sure they spend less time uh
in jail it's a pretty simple equation if
you have a problem with crime then you
need more people in jail and you need
them there
longer now is Cash bail a a plot to
criminalize or penalize poverty no it is
a way of keeping dangerous people in
jail and it's a way also of
incentivizing them to to come to court
that that's the whole point of bail um
or one of the central points is is uh
this is the collateral this is the
incentive if you don't come to court
then you lose the money if there's no
bail then what's the
incentive he doesn't even address that
point now it's not a perfect system by
any means there are plenty of people who
uh you know
the bail is put up by someone it's not
even their money and um and they still
won't show up to court but if there's if
there's no money if there's no bail then
there's no incentive for these people to
show up to
court and that's what you're going to
end up with which which of course is All
By Design thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast